this is what's left of Lahaina after
wildfires burnt down the historic town
on Hawaii's Maui Island
the destruction is so severe it's being
described as an apocalypse
thousands of people were forced to
escape the tourist spot any way they
could if anybody's still out here it's
time to go some left by boat the U.S
Coast Guard rescued 14 people who jumped
into the ocean
I was the last one off the dock when The
Firestorm came through the Banyan tree
and took everything with it and I just
ran out to the beach and I ran South and
I just helped everybody I could along
the way
I don't know when you can do
[Music]
meteorologists say Hurricane Dora
blowing across the Pacific Ocean is
partly to blame for the strong winds
Fanning the Flames
the winds knocked out power cell phone
services and grounded flights President
Biden says his sending assistance to
help local rescue efforts of those Three
Fires that have occurred that are
continuing uh here on our Island we have
had 13 evacuations from different uh
neighborhoods and and uh towns we've had
16 road closures we've opened five
shelters
uh and we've as a result of that
um our west side of our Island uh
Lahaina area was uh was cut off
new brush fires have sprung up on other
Hawaiian Islands
scientists say climate change is
contributing to The Blaze climate change
is resulting in a drier condition in the
Hawaiian Islands overall we have less
precipitation than we had in the past
and if that Trend continues then of
course the the possibility for wildfires
is also enhanced
say the extent of the damage caused by
the wildfires may not be known for
months the discouraging non-essential
travel to Maui for now Barbara angerpa
Al Jazeera
foreign